from huge reveals about vechna and the
mind flayer to a bombshell ending for 11
and the gang the final volume of
stranger things season 4 has finally
arrived yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and
in this video i'm explaining the big
season finale revealing some hidden
secrets you might have missed and what
to expect in season five spoilers ahead
of course so take care
at the end of season four during his
villains monologue beckner reveals he's
been the evil mastermind behind
everything all along after eleven sent
one into the upside down he explored the
new world and eventually came across a
massive unformed particles using his
powers he shaped these into a giant
spider form the mind flayer basing the
monster's look on the black widow
spiders he so admired as a child i saw a
means to realize my potential to
transcend my human form in fact the
young henry creel already had a vision
for the monster he would go on to create
many years later and his drawing is
uncannily similar to the one that will
made in season two this makes sense
because we now know that the mind flayer
was invented by one and he was therefore
controlling will at that moment back in
the upside down wekner had to wait for
11 to eventually open up a gate again to
the real world which she did
accidentally when she first made contact
with a demogorgon in season one but
because l fought back each time and
closed wekner's access to the world in
the first two seasons he decided on a
plan to take eleven's portal opening
powers for himself in season three i saw
a means to open my own doors i sought
your power he achieved this through the
spider monster which attacked eleven and
took her powers which were in turn
transferred to wekner who used them to
begin opening gates between the upside
down and hawkins in season four whenever
he made a kill
beckner's plan was to open four gates by
killing four teens something hinted at
through his clock which always chimed
four times whenever it appeared to one
of his intended victims the significance
of the number four might also be a
reference to the four horsemen of the
apocalypse which certainly seems
appropriate given the way the final
season ends after the four gates have
been opened and notice how in volume 1
the clocks at both hawkins lab and the
creel house were at three o'clock at
critical moments a clue to the three
victims that vekken had claimed by the
end of the first part of the season
the hawkins crew themselves come up with
a four-phase plan they hope will defeat
wekner the problem being that as good as
it might have been he already knew what
they had planned by appearing to max as
a vision of an angry lucas vetena traps
her in a twisted version of what should
be a happy memory for her of the
snowball dance at the end of season 2.
there was some ominous foreshadowing of
this moment in the way that season 2
ended with the camera flipping over to a
shot of the shadow monster watching over
the ball in the upside down wekner then
throws max across the room and pins her
against a wall just like eleven did to
him in the hawkins lab and to the
demogorgon in the school however when
eleven manages to break into max's
nightmare she propels vacna into the air
twisting him around and curling her
fingers and wrist similar to what he did
to her years earlier in the lab wekner
quickly recovers from this and
overpowers 11 sending her into his
mindscape and trapping her with his
vines this is exactly what brenna warned
11 about when he said that she wasn't
strong enough to confront wekner so
quickly after regaining her powers and
that she needed to learn more if you
want to stop one you will need to do
more than run you will need to fly at
that moment 11 wanted to leave
immediately to help her friends who she
knew were in danger in hawkins something
very reminiscent of how luke skywalker
wanted to leave his training with yoda
early to go and help leia and han solo
in the empire strikes back and there's
also shades of palpatine in wekner when
he tells 11 he wants her to watch him
execute his evil plan similar to how the
emperor tells luke to watch while he
destroys the rebellion
you will witness the end of your
insignificant rebellion at this point
wekner has broken eleven's will and it's
not until mike tells her how much he
loves her that vechna's vines shrink
away and she frees herself similar to
how max needed happy memories to escape
wekner's grip previously mike's
heartfelt words are what elle needs to
break free the moment calls back to
will's painting where he explained to
mike that because he's the one who leads
the group he has a coat of arms with a
heart on it as he's the one who holds
everyone together without heart we don't
fall apart even out by the way in season
one after will went missing mike was
browsing some similar paintings of will
and the d d crew going up against a
dragon another interesting detail about
will's painting is that when he shows it
to mike he claims that eleven asked him
to draw it did you paint this yeah i
mean i mean elle asked me to she
commissioned it basically i mean she
told me what to draw but this doesn't
match elle's voice over in the first
episode will is painting a lot but you
won't show me what he's working on it's
possible will is embarrassed to tell
mike why he really drew the painting so
he's pretending l asked him to do it
instead
the combined might of 11 pinning vechna
in his mindscape murray flaming the
demogorgons in russia and steven robbins
use of molotov cocktails weakens the
villain to the point that nancy can
finish him off with some close range
gunshots this sends him flying through
the creel house attic window to the
ground below where he appears to be
defeated however when they go downstairs
his body has disappeared this moment is
a homage to michael myers in the first
halloween movie where after being shot
and falling off a balcony he appeared to
be dead on the ground below however
moments later his body disappeared
proving the villain was still alive
there were also a few other halloween
references in volume 2 such as the way
wekner moves his head just before his
confrontation with 11 in a nod to
michael mayer's iconic head tilt and
eddie of course donned a michael myers
mask briefly as well
when elle finally gets back to hawkins
she goes to visit max who's now in a
coma the book lucas reads to max from is
the talisman by stephen king and peter
straub a story in which the protagonist
whose mother is dying travels into a
parallel universe where twinners or
doppelgangers of an individual also
exist interestingly the talisman is also
the duffer brothers and steven
spielberg's next project with netflix
although elle tries to go into the void
to connect with mac she gets no response
and i think max's recovery could be
contingent on eleven's eventual victory
over wekner in season five notice how
max tells luca she can't see or feel
anything after vechna's attack when one
kills he consumes he takes everything
from his victims their memories their
abilities so it may be that his defeat
will somehow release max's consciousness
back to her as there have already been
numerous illusions and references to how
wekner absorbs his victims with each
life i took i grew stronger they were
becoming a part of me and the coke
bottle that eleven finds under her bed
at hopper's old cabin is a call back to
the time she spun the bottle with max in
season 3 and used her abilities to
remotely spy on what mike and the other
boys were doing and saying the memory is
especially sad for elle because she
knows that right now she can't reach max
even with her powers
of course we have to talk about eddie
who made the ultimate sacrifice this
season there were various clues earlier
on to his fate such as him talking in
the first episode about how he'd finally
graduate and hand over the reins of the
hellfire club this year it's my year you
boys
the future of hellfire and how he kept
pointing out he wasn't a hero i see
danger and i just
turn heal and run there is no shame in
running don't try to be heroes the even
sadder thing is that eddie is still
being demonized and blamed for several
murders in hawkins by the media and the
community fortunately dustin who knows
the truth was at least able to tell
eddie's uncle that he died a hero saving
the town
as for eleven she got an emotional
reunion with her dad in his cabin and
noticed how she was still keeping her
door open a few inches just like she did
in the opening episode of season four
get the door open three inches and in
the very final scene will reveals he
knows wekner is still alive through the
connection he still has with the mind
player i can still remember what he
thinks and how he thinks and he's not
going to stop not until he's taken
everything and everyone and the hairs on
the back of his neck stand up just
before that final shot revealing that
the upside down has truly broken through
to the real world the flowers in this
field are rotting away similar to how a
pumpkin field began to decay after the
upside down's tunnels reached them in
season two you can also see the upside
down's characteristic red lightning
flashing over here where the main breach
appears to have occurred this basically
confirms the vision vetner gave to nancy
about what was to come downtown on fire
that soldiers this giant creature with a
gaping mouth there were so many monsters
an army it sounds like in season five we
could get a huge new monster and a slew
of other upside down creatures nancy's
comments about her family including mike
also sound very ominous he showed me my
mom holly mike we were all
and as powerful as eleven is i don't
think she can take on a whole army from
the upside down which means i think
she'll need to do something on a
different level to defeat wekner one
possible hint is this curious moment
where nancy points out argyle picking
some mushrooms in the woods just outside
the cabin some mushroom varieties can
have hallucinogenic effects and there
could be a possible connection here to
lucid dreaming potentially a different
way for eleven to battle with wekner on
a psychic level another possibility
given all of the back to the future
references in the series is that 11 will
perform some kind of time travel perhaps
to stop henry turning into a villain in
the first place and there's a big clue
to why i think that's happening in
season five in nancy's vision that
beckner gave her of the future but just
before i get to that i want to thank the
sponsor of this video nordvpn like the
government agents and stranger things
who listen in to everyone's phone calls
in hawkins your internet service
provider is also keeping a record of
every website you visit and in some
countries they can even sell your data
to third parties an easy way to stop
this is by using a trustworthy virtual
private network like nordvpn a vpn
encrypts your connection and prevents
your isp from monitoring your browsing
history or the emails and private
messages you send nord also has a threat
protection feature which blocks trackers
and annoying and intrusive ads making
your online experience a lot cleaner
safer and enjoyable if you accidentally
stumble across a shady site or phishing
link that downloads a malicious file to
your device nord will delete the malware
immediately plus with the nord security
bundle deal you'll get nodpass a
password manager that generates strong
passwords and stores them in a secure
vault and it also includes nordlocker an
encrypted cloud storage service perfect
for accessing your files securely from
anywhere in the world for a limited time
all our viewers can grab an exclusive
offer on a two-year plan with a huge
discount plus a bonus month completely
free just visit
nordvpn.comflix or go to the link in the
video description to get the offer or
use coupon code flicks when you check
out now if you watch extra slowly the
vision vechner gives to nancy while
she's in his grip there are not only
shots of the gates opening and ripping
through hawkins but there's also a shot
of the grandfather clock from the creel
house winding backwards similar to what
we saw during the reveal about young
henry creel in the seventh episode i
think the way the hands move in reverse
in both of these scenes together with
numerous other related easter eggs are a
big clue to time travel being part of
season five something i discuss in a lot
more detail in my time travel theory
video you can tap here to watch that or
follow the link in the video description
so movie lovers what do you think about
the ending of season four and do you
have any theories or predictions for
season five comment with your thoughts
below and if you enjoyed this video do
hit that like button i really appreciate
it you can also tap left to discover
more easter eggs and little details you
might have missed in season 4. thanks
for enjoying stranger things with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie loving
week yapikai movie lovers